en alemania país vecino de austria la
situación tampoco es muy alentadora y de
hecho la canciller saliente angela
merkel la describió como extremadamente
dramática tanto las autoridades
federales y regionales como el
parlamento alemán anunciaron estas
semanas nuevas medidas para tratar de
frenar ese aumento entre esas medidas se
encuentran restricciones para los no
vacunados en zonas de hospitalización
particularmente alta así como el acceso
a los lugares de trabajo o al transporte
público para personas que estén
completamente vacunadas que se hayan
recuperado del virus o que tengan una
prueba negativa tanto austria como
alemania tienen tasas de vacunación que
son bajas en comparación con otros
países de europa